merci quand j'étais tout jeune j'étais
un dévoreur de livres des romans des
ouvrages de science fiction des ouvrages
de sciences et parmi mes auteurs
préférés
il y avait stephen jay gould et douglas
hofstadter n'avaient pas leur pareil
pour entremêlés dans leur histoire les
aventures des humains les aventures des
idées les aventures des grands projets
l'art la culture les sciences tout
ensemble
stephen jay gould nous faisait rêver
avec des histoires de biologie évolutive
mon grand amour de jeunesse douglas
hofstadter nous entraîner dans des
aventures mathématiques incroyable c'est
dans ces ouvrages que j'ai entendu
parler pour la première fois d'alan
turing du développement de
l'intelligence artificielle et de toutes
autres sortes de sujets il ya la
mathématique et au reste et je pense que
ça a joué un rôle dans le fait que je
sois devenu mathématicien plus tard mais
le hasard des études a fait que je me
suis retrouvé mathématicien pas du tout
sur les sujets de prédilection d'eau
flatteur mais sur d'autres choses
passionnantes la physique mathématique
devant mais c'est quoi son chéri
physique mathématique problème de la
stabilité dans les plasmas problème de
la croissance de l'entreprise dans les
gaz des sujets très solide bien loin de
l'image de flou qu'avait l'intelligence
artificielle à cette époque
et quand l'un de mes collègues s'est
lancé là dedans dans l'intelligence
artificielle dans les années 2000 je dis
ce que tu sûr de ce que tu fais c'est un
sujet qu'il n'a pas abouti à grand chose
pour l'instant et comme je me trompe et
tout le monde se tromper personne
n'avait anticipé que ça reviendrait sur
le devant de la scène avec tant de force
ce sont les aléas et les rebonds des
sciences et puis moi aussi j'ai eu ma
dose d'aller à deux rebonds
l'histoire inattendue et quelques années
plus tard je me suis retrouvé députés en
charge d'un rapport pour le gouvernement
sur l'intelligence artificielle occupée
à me plonger dans le sujet et a écouté
des centaines d'experts nous parlant de
l'évolution de ce sujet intelligence
artificielle c'est passionnant parce que
finalement c'est beaucoup plus efficace
qu'on le croyait mais surtout sa
s'invite dans tous les domaines c'est un
sujet transversal ce un sujet dans
lequel il faut écouter les experts issus
d'innombrables horizon un sujet dont il
faut débattre publiquement pour que la
société puisse s'approprier l'évolution
pour qu'on invite des situations de
rejet pour qu'on permette à chacun
d'être acteur de cette évolution
quand on pense à l'intelligence
artificielle tout de suite des images
effrayantes viennent à l'esprit
on pense à savoir si les machines et les
algorithmes et viendront nous voler nos
emplois c'est une intelligence
surhumaine cherchera à prendre notre
contrôle comme dans le film de stanley
kubrick 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace
on peut craindre si comme la
mathématicienne quétier o'neal que ces
armes redoutables puisse être utilisé au
service de buts que l'on ne peut que
désapprouver et nous avons bien des
exemples dans lesquelles un mauvais
usage de l'intelligence artificielle
peut aboutir
à une destruction de la démocratie et ce
sont des peurs qu'il convient d'aborder
de façon posée en cherchant à faire tout
ce qu'il faut pour qu'elles ne se
réalisent pas intelligence artificielle
c'est aussi un sujet qui s'invite de
façon très positive dans nos rêves dans
ce que nous sommes capables de réaliser
dans des réalisations incroyables comme
celle qui mena deux miss as abyss à se
lancer dans la construction du meilleur
joueur de go jamais réalisé nous y
arrivons le programme alpha go grâce aux
techniques statistiques qui maintenant
font le coeur des méthodes
d'intelligence artificielle grâce aux
techniques de renforcement qui
permettent à l'algorithme de se
perfectionner dans les directions qui
n'ont jamais été essayé fut mis au point
un algorithme qui tu es plus fort que
n'importe quel joueur de go humain ce
qui n'empêcha pas d'ailleurs les ventes
de jeux de go à travers le monde à
travers le monde de grimper en flèche
signe que ce n'est pas parce que la
machine ou dépassent que nous changeons
nos habitudes
forcément et puis avec alpha go nous
avons appris des choses sur nous mêmes
en particulier que nous sommes de bien
plus mauvais joueur de go que nous le
croyons nous avions cette espèce
d'arrogance de penser qu'on était proche
de la perfection
et finalement on en était très loin et
on venait ici
l'un des buts essentiels des pionniers
d'intelligence artificielle comprendre
nous mêmes à travers le reflet que nous
tend l'algorithme
alors legault si extraordinaire ce que
ce soit très tard c'est un jeu mais on
peut impliquer l'intelligence
artificielle n'a d'autre but qui sont
d'intérêt vital en particulier la santé
et il ne fait pas de doute que certains
algorithmes souffrons l'avis de certains
d'entre nous dans le futur en matière de
santé c'est pas comme dans le gault on
connaît nos défaillances et nos
faiblesses
la difficulté de faire les diagnostics
et tous les biais qui sont afférents oui
cette image en haut à gauche
pardon si on peut revenir en arrière
merci oui cette image en haut à gauche
c'est une radio utilisée pour tester
l'acuité du diagnostic humain mais on
n'y a reproduit une variante d'une
expérience très connu en sciences de la
commission on ya inséré et vous le voyez
peut-être une image d'un gorille et
croyez-le ou pas la grande majorité des
experts à qui on demande d'analysé
l'image ne remarque pas qu'ils aient un
petit gorille qui a été inséré dans la
radio habitués qu'ils sont à détecter
certains type d'image et oui ce sont
oubliées nos habitudes et il faut en
avoir conscience
alors il ya d'autres problèmes en
médecine qui sont considérables en
particulier le fait que sa porte sur
tellement de paramètres tellement
pathologie possible qu'on a du mal à
identifier les leviers les tenants et
les aboutissants mais aussi certains
vous explique avec des arguments qu'il
faut prendre au sérieux que la majorité
de la recherche qui est publié dans ce
domaine dans d'autres sciences sciences
aux vivants sont fausses la plupart du
temps par manque de rigueur statistiques
cependant on a de grands espoirs sur le
fait qu'il ya une révolution qui est en
marche en médecine du fait qu' on a
accès à quantité nouvelles données par
rapport à nous mêmes et bien sûr la
possibilité de faire du séquençage
génomique à grande échelle mais aussi de
nouvelles méthodes d'exploration la
méthode clarity développé aux états unis
où une échographie du futur développer
en france dans le sillage des recherches
de mathias fink sur le retournement des
ondes
bref beaucoup nouvelles données qui vont
nous permettre de perfectionner notre
connaissance nous mêmes les données il
faut les interpréter
parfois c'est difficile dans l'un de ses
textes les plus marquants stephen jay
gould nous parler de son voyage émotif
et intellectuelle quand il a voulu en
savoir plus sur le cancer qui l'avait
touché lui même après l'opération le
voilà qui fouillent la littérature
scientifique sur ce sujet et qui
découvre qu'il n'a guère d'espoir à
avoir les statistiques sont déprimantes
la médiane de survie très basse et puis
il réfléchit et grâce à sa formation de
scientifiques comprend qu'il faut
prendre en compte toutes les données
statistiques et que finalement la
médiane n'est pas le seul indicateur
statistique est important pour lui et
finalement il a survécu à ce cancer
ceci nous rappelle combien il est
difficile d'interpréter des données
sophistiqués qu'elle soit en petit
nombre ou en grand nombre dans le cadre
but logique nous avons déconné
extraordinaire par exemple pour la
génétique et cette frustration
extraordinaire que nous savons si bien
connaître le génome et nous avons tant
de mal en définir en déduire le
phénotype la façon nous nous sommes
constitués l'intelligence artificielle
fournit une piste
pour résoudre ce dilemme d'une façon qui
n'est pas pleinement satisfaisante bien
sûr mais qui est impressionnante en
donnant à apprendre à l'algorithme
quantité d'exemples de génotype et de
phénotype
dans cet exemple le chercheur écart de
sabbatini dans un exposé à ted nous
montre comment fonctionne l'algorithme
comment il est capable par exemple de
reconstituer le visage probable à partir
du génome ici à droite le visage
reconstruit à partir de son propre
génome à gauche son vrai visage avec
quelques éléments plus il est vrai la
liberté de jouer sur son système pileux
tout petit peu d'embonpoint il répond
par rapport à la simulation mais quand
même une grande précision
ça fait rêver ça évoque aussi toutes
sortes de débats qui ne manquons pas de
se poser qui viendra témoigner devant le
tribunal de la fiabilité de telles
méthodes quand elles sont utilisées dans
des enquêtes et beaucoup beaucoup
d'autres sujets et puis l'intelligence
artificielle servira aussi pour la
formation pour l'entraînement de nos
médecins nos chirurgiens pour la
meilleure connaissance de nos organes
elle servira encore elle sert déjà à
faire des prothèses intelligente qui
s'adapte aux besoins des personnes à
permettre à des personnes handicapées de
découvrir nouvelle possibilité de
piloter un mécanisme un drone un cahier
par le mouvement des yeux ou même par la
pensée parmi les belles start-up
quantité de start up qui naissent sur ce
sujet sur le thème intelligence
artificielle et santé en france et
ailleurs
je mentionnerai cardiologue ce qui
s'occupe de faire du diagnostic
automatique à partir des
électrocardiogrammes une petite
révolution dans le domaine qui s'annonce
ou encore des rats pixels qui a remporté
tout récemment un concours mondial sur
la reconnaissance automatique de cancer
du sein à partir de mammographie signe
s'il en est et de la qualité des start
up française en la matière
dans un sujet dont l'intérêt s'annonce
de plus en plus grand avec
l'intelligence artificielle
le contact entre l'expert et les
personnes du secteur est vital que ce
soit au point de vue pragmatique au
point de vue théorique il ya quelques
années emmanuel quand des ce
mathématicien en poste à stanford
l'un des experts dans certains domaines
intelligence artificielle nous parler de
sa collaboration suivie avec des
médecins dans un hôpital pour mettre au
point de nouvelles techniques d'analysé
du signal qui permettent de réduire d'un
facteur 8 le temps qu'il nous faut pour
passer dans un scanner un exemple de
collaboration passionnante qui ouvre de
nouvelles voies et de nouveaux rêves
dans le dialogue entre la mathématique
et les autres disciplines avec
l'intelligence artificielle nous
emmenons aussi à mieux connaître notre
propre biologie et tout récemment grâce
à des techniques de reconnaissance
automatique d'image a été résolu une
controverse centenaire portant sur la
structure de notre cerveau l'existence
de ce que l'on appelle le fascicule
occipital verticale un exemple parmi
bien d'autres
des sujets fascinants des sujets qui
nous emmène vers de nouveaux horizons
scientifiques et les sujets qu'il va
s'agir aussi de mettre en musique au
mieux avec la société et les
entrepreneurs
à travers de nouveaux lieux pour le
dialogue
de nouveaux modes de collaboration comme
dans le projet collaboratif épidémie
sommes portés par un laboratoire
d'innovation citoyens la paillasse et
laboratoires roche mettant ensemble de
très nombreuses compétences au service
de la lutte automatique contre le cancer
pour autant le chemin est pavé
d'embûches
pas plus tard qu'hier lors d'une
conférence de presse avec le ministre en
charge du numérique
mounir mahjoubi je présentais les
premières conclusions le rapport d'étape
de notre mission sur l'intelligence
artificielle en faisant la liste de
nombreux freins sur ce domaine qui reste
à résoudre des questions liées à notre
politique d'économie et d'innovation il
ya notre système de formation des
barrières et notre organisation en
termes de collecte de partager données
qui sont si importants pour alimenter
les nouveaux algorithmes des freins
législatif matériel financier culturel
toutes sortes d'obstacles que nous
serons en mesure de vaincre
j'en suis sûr au niveau de la france est
au niveau de l'europe car le jeu en vaut
la chandelle et car il est passionnant
intelligence artificielle est un sujet
qui permet à toute la société de
dialoguer et qui nous permet aussi de
nous explorer nous même de découvrir
dans nos organisations humaines ou sont
oubliées nous forces et nos faiblesses
et de progresser c'est un sujet aussi
qui nous amène vers de nouveaux horizons
scientifiques passionnant tout récemment
j'ai laisé ouvrage le sni valiante l'un
des théoriciens les plus originaux de
l'informatique elle si ce temps sur le
fait qu'il va y avoir un fort parallèle
entre les performances
extraordinairement forte
inattendu des algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle immergeant par exemple des
techniques de réseaux neuronaux et les
performances incroyables inattendu qu'a
montré l'évolution des espèces à forte
des organismes complexes organisé
structuré de façon incroyablement
efficace finalement peut-être que
l'évolution des algorithmes et
l'évolution de la biologie est
intimement liés et peut-être que j'en
reviendrait par ce biais à m'intéresser
à mes amours d'enfance sur l'évolution
des espèces alors à coup sûr il s'agit
d'une histoire à suivre
plus ensemble je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]